[Musique]
les métiers liés à la montagne font
partie des métiers les plus risqués qu'
[Musique]
soit parmi eux le métier de cordiste les
accidents sont rares mais lorsqu'ils
surviennent ils sont souvent mortel on
déplore une vingtaine de décès par an en
France le métier de guide de haute
montagne fait face à un nombre plus
important d'accidents toujours fatal
mais toujours
dramatique Sébastien bonjan est cordiste
depuis que le métier est reconnu il en
connaît beaucoup d'aspect mais doit sans
cesse s'adapter à de nouvelles
tâches vous avez une corde là quand je
me suis retourné il y avait plus
personne donc il y a une chute pour une
raison que je n'ai pas encore pu
expliqué Gérard Otavio est président du
bureau des guides de Valtournanche il a
perdu l'un des siens l' année
dernière les clients eux ont survécu
elle n'a pas réussi à se sauver et nous
l'avons
perdu Sébastien et Gérard sont de
travailleurs de la montagne qui jouent
tous les jours avec le vide un milieu à
risque qui les oblige à bien s'assurer
c'est
[Musique]
génial
nous sommes au début de l'été et pour
Sébastien c'est la
reprise comme beaucoup de cordistes
Sébastien est
saisonnier il travaille dans une station
de ski tout l'hiver l'été il fait des
travaux sur corde pour une entreprise
spécialisée dans le
domaine aujourd'hui pour sa première
journée il va renforcer l'équipe d'un
très beau chantier on l'a missionné pour
apporter un outil qui va devenir
indispensable à la progression des
travaux c'est un verin il y a un
trépied il y a un manomètre c'est mon
outil c'est c'est l'outil de de en
général du du du chef de chantier qui va
vérifier les ancrages de son chantier
tout à
fait une opération bénine à terre mais
bien plus compliquée quand on doit
l'exécuter à plusieurs mètres du sol
vendu à une corde l'opération est
périlleuse Sébastien est cordiste depuis
une dizaine d'années c'est un métier
plutôt récent qui est reconnu par un
code depuis 2008 seulement cordiste
c'est plutôt une manière de travailler
en sécurité de se déplacer sur corde et
d'accéder à des des
sites d'accès difficile donc des
falaises des dessous de toit des des
dessous de pontfin T des des métiers où
on ne pourrait pas accéder avec des
échelles des nacelles la corde en fait
est vraiment un aspect sécurité et un
aspect de déplacement c'est un moyen
d'accès au
chantier
aujourd'hui Sébastien se rend en Italie
via le tunnel du Montblanc il est
attendu par Richard son chef de
chantier rendez-vous de l'autre côté du
tunnel car l'accès au site est plus
court par
l'Italie bonjour
Richard aujourd'hui c'est une journéeage
de maté
is ce pour rendre sur le
chantier Sébastien se rend sur un lieu
de travail à près de 3400 m d'altitude
un chantier sur le toit de
[Musique]
l'Europe chantier est destiné à
renforcer le soubassement de l'arrivée
du fameux télécabine de la traversée des
glaciers
[Musique]
allez
monsieur ça va ça va et toi nickel
salett le
boudrier sécurité
avec Sébastien va mettre maintenant 10
minutes à s'équiper il utilise un
protocole de sécurité très
strict compagnon de sécurité c'est un
petit charot qui va être placé sur une
deè ce de
sécurité quand on monte quand on descend
et voilà qui coulisse et en cas de chute
pour une raison X ou Y ce char va
automatiquement bloqué donc c'est c'est
une sécurité supplémentaire qui est
obligatoire de toute façon tu as des
gantesas des lunettes
oui c'est un milieu où faut faire
attention à tout quand vous descendez
sur corde à tout ce qui se passe aux
alentours à l'environnement quoi c'est
que on n pas à l'abri de que ça casse
quoi et puis surtout
c'est notre vie quoi donc du coup on est
obligé de on est obligé d'être prudent
par rapport à ça et puis dès que c'est
abîé faut faut changer
quoi aller voir gars et puis aprs on va
aller chercher le
vin l'accès au chantier ça l'acès au
chantier
donc le travail sur ce commence ici pour
Bastien à partir de maintenant aucune
faute de sécurité ne sera
tolérée une belle journée d'automne
commence dans la vallée la plus réputée
d'Italie Gérard a rendez-vous avec un
client pour profiter de cette météo
clémente et l'entraîner à gravir l'un
des sommets les plus mythiques des
nous allons faire uneata avec un ami à
moi qui désire vraiment un jour escaler
le en montagne lesents restz de simples
C c'est une question de rapprochement
cré par un environnement et une aventure
exceptionnelle le rapport qui se crée
après avoir été un peu en montagne
devient automatiquement un rapport
d'amitié
parce que partir en montne crment
du au du fait que par une ce souvent
presque tout le temps ça dép de ce qu'on
va
faire mais il vraiment un rapport de
confiance qui est
[Musique]
réciproantire falaise est très verticale
c'est l'endroit parfait pour appréhender
le
vide avant de débuter une ascension
aussi difficile que le Servin Gérard
veut s'assurer que Marco sera à l'aise
dans les manœuvres de cordes et sera
capable de bien réagir en cas de
problème car dans une ascension sur
corde la vie du guide dépend aussi de
son
client
c'est très important aussi car
aujourd'hui c'est une première journée
d'approche avec un test sur la viaerata
et qui permet de commencer déjà à nous
comprendre moi et le client et nous
commençons à trouver cette
symbiose la gestion de la corde entre le
guide et le client et donc même sur une
voie de montagne classique on a déjà
essayé la corder et ça c'est une bonne
okago
[Musique]
nous venons ici car on dit que c'est
très exposé et très vertical alors nous
allons tester ma
[Musique]
résistance
moi j'utilise ceci pour la corde je mets
la corde à l'intérieur et tu dois
seulement l'enlever quand j'ai mis le
prochain
entetemps même si tu traverses tu mets
une longe comme ça même si tuis glisser
tu resterais quand même
attaché donc avant de partir j'attends
toujours que tu passes la ce dans
l'autre transmise et c'est parti pour
une ascension de 3
He 3 He durant lesquelles il faudra
garder une vigilance de tous les
instants c'est une partie où la roche
est glissante à cause des passages
répét après la partie très glissanteard
Marco vont en attaquer une
particulièrement verticale c'est le
passage le plus dangereux et c'est
surtout dans ces momentslà que la corde
est
[Musique]
[Rires]
indispensable
la Via afferrata en elle-même faite de
manière classique a toujours un risque
le risque peut même être très élevé car
en cas de chute ce qu'on appelle le
facteur de chute est très élevé on
s'arrête certes on ne chute pas jusqu'en
bas mais plus on est loin du point
d'arrêt plus on risque justement de se
blesser à cause du choc brutal que l'on
subit en
chutant et ça c'est le plus gros risque
qui
existe si Marco n'avait pas de corps en
cas de chute il ne serait retenu que par
sa longe le problème c'est qu'elle ne le
retiendrait qu'après plusieurs mètres de
chute ce qui pourrait le blesser très
[Applaudissements]
grièvement Sébastien s'apprête à
descendre sur corde sa mission tester le
premier forage d'ancrage il ne doit
jamais se déplacer sans doubler toutes
ses
sécurités
là j'ai placé mon descendeur pour lequel
je vais faire une clé pour le moment
verrouiller le temps de me
délonger il y a touours une appréhension
mais l'appréhension elle passe très vite
on arrive sur le chantier avec
l'expérience on a vite vite évaluer les
risques sur un chantier ici qui est
quand même très confiné qui est quand
même petit c'est une petite
zone chose importante ce petit nud là au
bout de la corde c'est pas du tout fait
par hasard c'est un petit nœud d'arrêt
si jamais pour une RA X ou Y ça nous
arrivait que un de nos appareils de
descente ou de monter glisse sur la
corde c'est un nœud qui nous arrête et
qui évite d'aller au bout de la corde et
donc de filer en
bas bah la auamo il doit avoir 50
m on part en arrière on va jusqu'en bas
considère que dans une dans une porde à
plus de
25° chute on ne se rattrape pas dans le
1ier mtre c'est impossible de se
rattraper derrière
donc l'objectif du chantier est de
consolider le sous-bassement du bâtiment
il accueille tous les touristes à
l'arrivée des
télécabines pour cela il faut
resolidariser les
rchesentreelle la technique est de les
ancrer ensemble grâce à des tiges
d'acier qui pénètrent à 5 m de
profondeur ve quoi ces tiges doivent
résister à 28 tonnes l'opération est
titanesque il faut mettre en place grâce
à des cordes une foreuse en pleine paroi
de plus de 1500 kg et la déplacer à la
[Applaudissements]
main les risques d'un tel chantier
n'expose pas que les cordistes 50 m plus
bas des randonneurs sont entrés dans un
périmètre dangereux ils sont sortis du
chemin et peuvent se prendre à n'importe
quel moment des pierres sur la
tête passe par en bas
[Applaudissements]
le Vrain qu' apporté ce matin Sébastien
va exercer par pression le poid de 28
ton sur les d'acier l'opération est
obligatoire vont être test et un rapport
de conformité devra tre four au
autorités
suspendu à une corde la manipulation est
difficile on a on a dû s'y reprendre à
trois fois euh à zéro pour le pourquoi
parce que le terrain il s'est tassé
comme tu peux le voir là
Pascal le terrain il est descendu en
fait donc plutôt que ce soit qu'on tire
sur la barre c'est le terrain qui
descend donc forcément c'est totalement
faussé donc on a dû repartir à zéro
resserrer le verin pour repartir sur
quelque chose de stable et de remettre à
zéro donc là en l'occurrence on est à 10
tonnes Richard c'est ça on est à 10 là
on a tiré à 10 tonnes et la barre a
bougé de 0,02 mm c'està-dire rien du
tout donc pour le moment on est tout à
fait sereinon voilà en sachant qu'on
doit aller à 28 ton on pas bougé ça
devrait bien se passer on n pas bougé ça
mettre en
pression voilà c'est ça en fait ça
plusieurs
fois tu peux faire toi reste longer là
laissant une 10
[Musique]
minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
séastien va passer une semaine sur le
chantier la plupart du temps les
cordistes sont en grand déplacement loin
de chez eux alors pour plus de confort
et de solidarité il se retrouve dans un
même logement et partage les mêmes repas
une bonne occasion pour chacun de
raconter ses expériences il a eu des
sururfroides rappel qui descendent plus
vite que prévu ou des choses où qu'on
fait qui se passent très bien et que
avec un peu de recul on se dit ou là
mais c'est j'aurais pas dû faire ça
c'était tendu voilà parce qu' on a beau
être vigilant on a beau être
expérimenter après on reste des humains
et puis on pe toujours faire des erreurs
voilà ça j'avais fait un rappel italien
et du coup bah je savais plus quel sur
quel cordre remonter et puis bah du coup
je suis arrivé en haut et ben
heureusement enfin j'avais les deux
j'étais monté sur les deux cordes et
puis puis j'étais monté sur la mauvaise
quoi et du coup tout le long j'ai bien
j'ai bien eu
peur en aiguille au début les
statistiques en travaux sur corde c'est
c'est minime enfin par rapport aux
accidents mais c'est fatal par contre
c'est dit enfin on en a eu l'expérience
aussi avec
Seb il y a quelques années Sébastien a
lui-même vécu une histoire dramatique
dans son métier c'est un chantier qui
sitit dans le Val de fierre donc dans
dans la région de
lin on était deux et puis j'étais occupé
à faire quelque chose à faire une
manipulation de déplacement d'une
machine de forage et puis quand je me
suis retourné il y avait plus personne
donc il y a eu une chute pour une raison
que je n'ai pas encore pu expliquer
personnellement personne n'a pu
expliquer vu qu'il y avait personne
d'autre euh voilà a priori voilà un
accident un tragique
[Musique]
accident
Gard et Marco s'apê à franchir le
passage le plus difficile de la
viata
il biener
de
[Musique]
sur je pe don de touru
suré qu tu mement tu utilis le BR en
fermeture tutig l tu
Mones je monte en premier quand je suis
là-haut je te dis tu peux venir comme ça
tu y vas e moi je t'assure
toujours j'ai
[Musique]
fuoriilà quello che
riesce è fisica ma un po' di
tecnica un po' di strapiombo e
via
[Musique]
après le passage le plus difficile c'est
le passage le plus impressionnant celui
du pont de
[Musique]
singe peine arrivé c'est au tour de
Marco de se présenter les pas doivent
être précis et assuré sur le câble
d'acier suspendu en haut du
vide
je pensais que ça aurait été plus
difficile mais c'est très excitant c'est
différent car c'est un câble en
métal les derniers pas sont proches et
c'est sur une vue magnifique du
montservin que Gérard passe à corde dans
le dernier
anneau les deux hommes sont heureux ils
ont réussi leur voie avec succès
mais la journée n'est pas finie pour les
deux hommes Gérard veut maintenant
mettre Marco dans un environnement
d'escalade plus
difficile on pouvoir faire encore un peu
d'escalade mais sur une partie on va
dire un peu plus
technique en réalité pour faire le
Servin ce qu'il faudrait maintenant
c'est faire quelques sorties plus en
situation plus en montagne en haute
montagne la willia de l'altitude et donc
progresser petit à petit un pas après
l'autre
jusqu'à pouvoir faire l'ascension du
Servin ecco bravo po oui bravo là tu
pourrais passer un peu plus à ta gauche
c'est plus simple
Marco bravissim
ce que nous faisons là c'est déjà de
l'escalade sportive on appelle ça comme
ça et c'est une étape
indispensable parce que bon on est
toujours en sécurité bien sûr avec la
corde mais le terrain permet d'être un
peu plus technique on apprend à
escalader à se positionner correctement
mais toujours en
sécurité à cette hauteur sans ce on peut
pas griper çarait beaucoup TR
risqué
l'avantage de prendre un guide quand on
est client est évidemment qu'il est en
premier de corder c'est lui qui ouvre la
voie et prend les plus grands risques de
chute pour le second cordé les risques
sont minimes puisquil se retrouve en cas
de chute tout de suite retenu par la
corde c'est beaucoup plus simple
beaucoup plus serein aussi pour le
mental il y a la corde làhaut et avec la
corde est plus
facileour
de TER la voard n'est pas passé par
l'endroit le plus facile mais c'est
volontaire comme ça il rencontre un peu
de
difficultéut qu'il doiv se débrouiller
un peu pour réussir à passer à bien
utiliser les pieds
ok Marco c'est quand tu
veux pour Marco la partie ne va pas être
simple mais grâce à Gard il est en
confiance
etuliement
pour si la difficulté technique est plus
élevée que sur le Servin il sera donc
bien
[Musique]
[Rires]
préparé c'est maintenant le temps de la
redescente là encore il va falloir faire
entièrement confiance à son guide pour
se laisser suspend dans le vide au bout
d'une simple
corde sur le chantier d'elbrunner les
cordistes sont déjà à l'œuvre
aujourd'hui l'équipe doit projeter du
béton pour consolider la structure en
surface le béton est armé de pièces
métalli pour renforcer la matière
ensuite il est envoyé sous haute
pression dans les tuyaux au bout la
lance est tenue à la main l'opération
est périlleuse car bien évidemment tout
va se faire sur
corde pour la première fois Sébastien va
participer à ce genre d'opération c'est
ça le métier de cordiste savoir tout
faire mais pendu au bout d'une corde
mais pas question pour Sébastien de
tenir la lance cela demande une
expérience préalable ça c'est pour le
moment l'affaire de Richard Sébastien
lui va simplement tenir le tuyau pour
l'aider dans sa manœuvre ce qu'il faut
surtout pas c'est que le le tuyau se
pince parce que sinon à l'ouverture
Richard mon pauvre décolle ce poste est
difficile à tenir alors pour l'aider Max
va se tenir en retrait et lui indiquer
tous les gestes qu'il doit faire pour la
sécurité de Richard mais aussi pour la
sienne si la lance sous pression est
lâchée c'est la catastrophe elle
deviendra incontrôlable et ça sera
l'accident assuré max en a déjà fait les
frais pas longtemp à l'éiguie du midi
une erreur humaine j'ai ouvert la vanne
sans le vouloir j'ai pas réussi à tenir
le tuyau et je l'ai pris en pleine
figure et ça m'a cassé le nez rien de
bien grave ça la cassé nette le
lendemain j'étais au boulot je vite à
l'hôpital je me suis soigné et et voilà
mais bon même en ayant l'habitude comme
quoi faut rester
vigilant faut aussi être conscient que
comme d'autres métiers que que la
accident que le risque nul zéro n'existe
pas et qu' peut arriver quelque chose
faut en être conscient tous les jours
voilà il faut pas ignorer ça et et faire
abstraction de
Sal le métier de cordiste combine les
dangers du déplacement sur corde avec
les dangers lié au travaux du bâtiment
ici on peut même dire que le mélange des
deux est explosif chaque incident peut
être source
d'accident
oui ben je
t'écouteom d'avoir le même compresseur
qui sarrête comment ça se passe ah
[__] arrêtez le
béton
arrête l'autre là s'il te
plaît ferme la VAN il a l'air de
chauffer je pense que
non fort le bruit qu'il fait quand il
essa de démarrer
je crois que jeis appeler le mécano
quand même parce que ça va passer mes
compétences à un moment
là tu le
remets comme
ça
faire toujours très attention au tuyau
d'air c'est pour ça qu'ils ont des
sécurités comme ça pas oublier que c'est
un neu barre à l'intérieur et que si un
tuau se décroche quand on passe ou une
erreur de manipulation on peut la
prendre sur nous et des des cas de
blessure dans ces cas-là c'est l'erreur
très bête ça arrive super facilement
faut vraiment y faire
attention mais le compresseur ne veut
rien savoir impossible de le redémarrer
pour aujourd'hui toute l'équipe est
bloquée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut être ordonné parce que voilà là
il y a une multitude de cordes dans tous
les sens il y a des câbles il y a des
lignes d'air euh si on commence à à
mettre tout dans le désordre et que
chaque matin on met une demi-heure à à
défaire les nœuds et et les cordes et
ben on avance plus accidentogène aussi
c'est accidentogène exactement parce
qu'on ne se rend plus compte sur quoi on
est pendu sur quoi on est accroché c'est
comme ça qu'on se trompe de brin du Glac
c'est rangé on sait que celle-là elle
est levée elle est prête à l'emploi
quand on en a besoin des l et puis voilà
c'est replié on en parle plus c'est un
gain de temps et et on préserve le
matériel surtout le matériel qui sert à
notre sécurité c'est encore plus
important l'hiver est précoce dans la
vallée d'aost nous sommes à peine en
automne et il neige déjà
abondamment
alors pour Gérard il n'est plus possible
d'emmener qui que ce soit en
[Musique]
montagne c'est sûr il faut savoir
renoncer changer de sortie ou faire
autre
chose
c'est il faut vraiment prendre des
décisions en toute sérénité et dire non
aujourd'hui on fait rien on renonce on
essa une autre fois fait parti de
alin Marco vient alors rendre son
matériel l'escalade c'est finie pour la
saison une décision qu'il accepte sans
regret de toute façon la montagne est là
personne ne va la
déplacer la prudence doit toujours
rester de mise quand on est un alpiniste
et encore plus un guide Gérard le sait
mieux que quiconque il a perdu une
collègue l'année dernière
simonaos exercit son métier de guide
depuis 4 ans elle s'est fait emporter à
à peine 30
[Musique]
ans ça c'est le livre sur l'histoire des
guides du
Servin et là c'est un texte tiré du
carnet intime de Simona dans lequel elle
écrit j'ai choisi l'alpinisme car on est
seul face à
soi-même pour faire le vide à chaque pas
accompli pour être libre à chaque
instant je sais que je risque beaucoup
en suivant mes
passions en allant à la recherche de
moi-même et de mes émotions seulement
pour comprendre qui je suis pour
découvrir mon âme et la sentir
vibrer ça s'est passé en hiver c'était
l'un de nos guides la seule guide femme
et aussi la première à faire partie de
l'histoire de la Société des guides du
Servin
elle s'appelait
simonaos une guide très compétente et
alpiniste
aussi malheureusement elle est décédée
sous une
avalanche durant une sortie piste avec
des
clients les clients eux ont survécu mais
elle n'a pas réussi à se sauver et nous
l'avons
perdu le métier de guide est
tragiquement lié avec la mort en
montagne chacun en a bien conscience
composé avec les décès de ses
collègues c'est une réalité avec
laquelle tu vis
toujours donc c'est pas parce qu'il y a
des accidents qu'on va s'arrêter pour
autant de partir en
montagne on va de l'avant même si ça
reste en nous une cicatrice pour
toujours moi j'y pense je pense souvent
à elle ça me revient à l'esprit les
projets qu'on avait
ensemble j'ai fait aussi des sorties en
montagne avec
elle rien d'extraordinaire mais je me
souviens qu'elle était quelqu'un qui
avait une véritable passion pour la
montagne
sans cette passion il serait impossible
pour les guides de repartir en montagne
c'est toute l'histoire de l'alpinisme
qui le monte à l'étage du bureau des
guides un petit musée est consacré au
Servin et là encore son histoire s'est
écrite dans le
[Musique]
sang en plus d'être la première
ascension du Servin et donc la réussite
de l'escalade d'une montagne considéré
jusque là comme uneacess
c'est aussi le premier drame de
l'alpinisme parce que durant l'ascension
et puis durant la descente qu personnes
de la cord wimper vont
mourir c'était les premiers alpinistes
du
Servin aujourd'hui chaque guide a bien
conscience que la mort fait partie
intégrante des risques encourus dans le
métier car souvent la chute en haute
montagne est
fatale je sais que peuttre un jour je
pour R ma femme aussi sait mes enfants
sont encore trop jeunes il ne peuvent
pas encore comprendre tout ça si demain
mon fils voulait suivre ce
chemin je lui dir d'être le plus
vigilant possible mais je ne pourrais
pas lui dire de ne pas le
faire les chantiers en travaux acrobati
sont toujours des chantiers à risque
alors même si les cordistes sont aguér
au protocole de sécurité il est toujours
important de la garantir au maximum
Julien be est le patron de la société
acrtp cordiste de formation il connaît
parfaitement les risques du métier et
s'assure lui-même de sa bonne mise en
œuvre aujourd'hui c'est important de
faire le tour des chantiers pour pour
veiller un petit peu l'aspect
sécuritaire parce qu'ils ont quand même
une pression de productivité on va dire
régulière en même temps fa les protéger
quoi nous sommes dans les Alpes
Maritimes dans les gorges de la Mescla
le chantier de Julien est
particulièrement isolé en pleine
paroi son rôle est de retenir les
pierres d'un ébouli
elles peuvent en effet à tout moment
chuter de 150 m sur une zone
d'exploitation hydraulique en contrebas
mais le lieu est particulièrement meuble
et les accidents
fréquents
à pas mal d'accidents dernièrement
historiquement ça fait des années qu'il
font des travaux à donc on a clairement
eu dès le début le mod c'était pas de
blessé donc c'est comme d'hab ça c'est
attention personnelle sur chantier qui
est pas accidentogène particulièrement
et on va descendre
mettez-vous à
l'abri la chute des pierres est le
risque majeur ici pour les cordistes
avec la glissade et la chute de personne
pasil a bien la bavette encore on va pas
aller lui remplir dessous la
bavette il y a quand même du
danger oui quand
même il y a un peu de gaz
quoi a bonne marche de 150 m mais il y a
également une petite barrière provisoire
à laav donc bon c'est on reste dans dans
un un milieu austère de
cordist les ouvriers ici utilisent leur
technique de progression sur corde pour
accéder au chantier sur place ils
peuvent tenir debout mais le danger peut
arriver à n'importe quel moment et de
n'importe où
c'est le pierrier quoi se balader
là-dedans là c'est vraiment rivière de
cailloux quoi du coup voilà quoi les
petites terrasses qu'on a fait ça nous
aide bien mais au départ c'est un peu ça
puis après il y a la zone en bas là avec
100 150 m
plein c'est quoi que tu as sur ton
casque mon prénom et mon Rouple sanguin
dans un souci de réactivité si jamais il
arrive un accident ou quelque chose les
informations sont sur le casque
directement attention à toi ok pourquoi
ben disons qu'après ça va être le risque
naturel qui va rentrer en jeu mais
techniquement on fait tout pour que
justement il y ait pas ce ce Dr qui
[Musique]
arrive visiblement Julien est rassuré la
sécurité sur son chantier est respectée
son inspection est
satisfaisant le du jeu c'est quand même
d'avoir nos gars puis de de viser le
risque
zé attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
retour avec Gérard ce matin il se
prépare un événement qui n'a lieu que
tous les 2 ans alors pour l'occasion il
va se mettre sur son
31 aujourd'hui nous avons rassemblement
avec les membres du Club des Amis du
serv ce club toutes les personnes qui
ont escaladé le Servin avec un guide de
notre
association dire Valtournanche à la
salle des fêtes du
village le héros du jour le mont Servin
au programme projection de film et
hommage au pionniers italiens de
l'Ascension bonjour et bienvenue à vous
tous premier hommage ant car il est le
premier guide avoir réalisé l'ascension
du Servin du côté italien il est le myth
fondateur du bureau des guides mais sa
vie se termine tragiquement sur les
pentes même du serv il y est décédé
d'épuisement en
1890 en redescendant du sommet après
plusieurs
enchaînements aujourd'hui il est
question de remplacer sa croix à
l'endroit même de son décès pour ne
jamais
oublier
la tradition en Italie est quelque chose
de fondateur elle montre ici le respect
pour le métier de
guide pour moi c'est très important car
ça fait partie de la
traditionino a créé ce club avec
justement l'idée de se
retrouver je suis fi de lui de ce qu'il
fait mais comme je disais tout à l'heure
c'est un métier plutôt
dangereux donc quand il part il y a
toujours un peu de
peur lorsqu'il revient par contre il y a
la magie du retour et la joie d'être
ensemble et pour bien clôturer la fête
les amis du Servin vont se retrouver à
table pour le reste de l'après-midi
quand les Italiens FAI c'est en grande
pompe
[Musique]
je vous présente mon ami her Barnas qui
est guide alpin du Servin et
alpiniste on est ami
oui Hern est le guide du bureau de la
vallée d'OST plus doué sa génération
Hervé a réalisé de nouvelles voies
notamment sur le Servin avec son père
lui aussi guide de la vallée d'aost puis
il a enchaîné avec des solitaires la
façon la plus difficile et surtout la
plus risquée de réaliser des itinéraires
en
montagne le secret d'un alpiniste si on
regarde les alpinistes qui ont réussi à
vieillir je veux dire Bonatti Mesner et
d'autres est toujours dans le fait de
chercher à comprendre est-ce que tu es
en mesure de dépasser tes limites sans
risquer ta
vie et de chercher à le faire le moins
possible parce que lorsque tu t'exposes
à des risques trop importants comme à la
montagne tout n'est jamais sous
contrôle et donc un accident peut se
produire d'un moment à
l'autre en tant qu'alpiniste j'ai déjà
pris des risque et je suisit
pe her s'est retrouvé au Pakistan en
tant qu'instructeur pour locaux et lors
d'une ascension d'une cascade de glace
tout a failli
[Musique]
basculer par miracle l'avalanche est
déroulé en plein milieu de la cascade de
glace alors qu'erv avait décidé d'ouvrir
un itinéraire complètement sur la gauche
une décision qui lui a sauvé la
vie
her ça
va il va
[Musique]
bien je pense qu'on a eu de la
chance à 1 heure près on était tous
morts tous ouais
tous pour moi ça s'est bien passé mais
je connais beaucoup de gens dont des
amis qui malheureusement sont décédés à
la
montagne aujourd'hui Sébastien a été
mandaté par son patron pour prêter main
forte sur un autre chantier il ne va pas
être déçu c'est le plus haut d'Europe
sur l'Aiguille du Midi elle-même à 3842
m
d'altitude un nouveau chantier et de
nouveaux cordistes l'attendent ça va
parfait
bien nana dans notre métier c'est bien
pu bon on se connaît depuis de longues
dates donc du coup voilà ça va combien
de
temps à peu près 13
minutes voilà c'est le principe du
métier on a la même couleur donc c'est
bon ce qu' déjà c'est le principe du
métier c'est exactement ça c'est dire de
découvrir de nouvelle tête un peu tout
le temps et puis et puis découvrir des
endroits aussi découvrir des endroits ou
c'est vrai des endroits c'est sympa en
général quand même l'occurrence tu va
être plus que
sympa pour accéder au sommet Anne et
Sébastien emprunte un ascenseur de
chantier un privilège pour eux car aucun
touriste ne peut accéder à cet endroit
magique qui est le sommet de l'Aiguille
du Midi le site est encore interdit au
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
public
aujourd'hui Sébastien va donc faire
équipe avec Anne une alpiniste qui a
fait partie de l'équipe de France
d'alpie leur mission du jour nettoyer
les parois vitrées du pas dans le vide
qui doit bientôt
réouvrir et c'est pendu à 3842 m qu'ils
vont devoirvrer à cette hauteur il faut
mieux être bien
accrocher verrouille
tjours
10 m ou 1000 m après il faut pas tomber
donc c'est pareil c'est la même
vigilance c'est le boulot c'est le
boulot voilà ça c'est le quotidien c'est
deux cordes et voilà je veux dire il y a
pas le fait qu'on soit haut qu' c'est
pas parce qu'on est plus haut qu'on
s'assure
plus après avoir aidé à projeter du
ciment en paroi voilà Sébastien simple
laveur de vitre fa sair tout faire en
fait c'est là où on bien que cord c'est
pas métier résume bien c'est la corde
c'est vraiment notre moyen d'accès ah
ben moi je suis pas d'accord avec toi
non non sinon un guide il est il est
quoi alors pour il se balade il est sur
qu la manipulation des cordes c'est vrai
voilà il y a il y a surtout le
ouais je m'exprime mal c'est comme je
disais mardi on peut être cordiste maçon
on peut être cordiste charpentier on
peut être cordiste laveur de vitre c'est
de la polyvalence c'est de la
polyvalence voilà je me suis mal exprimé
j'ai d'ailleurs été repris très
justement par ou non non mais ça fait
partie du métier moi je suis pas
d'accord avec ceux qui disent que c'est
pas un métier c'est un métier à part
entière et ce qu'il faut c'est réussir
àind de à joindre les deux quoi c'est ça
qui est
compliqué le métier de cordiste est en
effet un métier apparentière depuis
quelques années il est reconnu en tant
que tel pour le pratiquer il faut donc
détenir un certificat de qualification
professionnelle de cordiste oui ça c'est
très important faut tout attacher en
sachant que
sous nous il y a une
passerelle des moment ce moment passe à
peu près 4000 personnes par jour donc
c'est sûr que faut rien laisser tomber
on travaille sans
fidne et Sébastien ont préparé leur
amarage en vérifiant scrupuleusement
l'un et l'autre leur assurage
respectif c'est
[Musique]
génial je devrais pas
mal cette fois-ci Sébastien va devoir se
mettre plein vide ça va benah il y a a
on va pas dire une appréhension il y
a il il y a de l'ambiance quoi comme on
disait tout à l'heure il y y a de
l'ambiance il y a de la hauteur mais bon
voilà après c'est aussi notre not notre
de l'expérience on doit apprendre à
voilà
être c'est notre milieu quoi c'est dans
le milieu dans lequel on est évolue donc
on doit on doit s'y habituer et
l'appréhender correctement c'est le
moment maintenant pour nos deux
cordistes de passer à la phase de
nettoyage et comme n'importe quels
employés qui font connaissance ils
parlent de leur vie en oubliant
complètement le vide qui est sous eux tu
es originaire d'où toi à la base
Lorine et toi moi je suis belge
ah
ah bon ben désolé bah oui
hein et belge de de où ah oui parce que
tu as pas l'AC ça fait ans que
d'accord hein l'ENT il est un petit peu
parti
[Musique]
ouais
c'est pas tous les jours comme ça faut
pas croire mais c'est ces journées là
qui font justement qu'on on aime ça on
continue Hervé vient de se faire opérer
des cervicales suite à ses nombreux
accidents en
montagneéci
il est lui
d'eration les CICAT
genou CCI C j'ai interention j'ai
accient pourise en condition un
programme bien PRC lu étécrit par les
médecs qui
opér pas question d' allerop brutalement
les risques de se faire mal sont bien
trop
grands pas vraiment raînement c'est
moins intense mais c'est
utile difficile pour un sportif de haut
niveau de repartir à zéro dans la mise
en forme a une volonté de faire et il
prendra tout le temps qu'il faut pour
remettre son corps à
niveau la récupération est une étape
fondamentale pour pouvoir ensuite faire
des entraînements plus dur et donc faire
de belles escalades en
montagne mais là il faut encore un peu
de
temps après sa séance de musculation
HERV se dirige maintenant vers son
milieu favori la
[Musique]
montagne pour récupérer il faut beaucoup
de
patience on ne peut pas se dire que du
jour au lendemain on fait ce qu'on veut
juste parce que le médec l'
[Musique]
dit rééduqué avec patience il a atteint
les plus hauts niveaux de l'alpinisme
mais cela lui a coûté beaucoup
aujourd'hui il est diminué physiquement
mais garde toute sa volonté de revenir
au sommet de sa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
forme
bien bien c'est pas
mal on recommence à se bouger donc tout
va très bien il faut un peu de temps
bon et puis avec la neige tout est beau
moi j'aime l'hiver je suis né le 21
décembre
aujourd'hui Hervé rêve de reconquérir
les sommets les plus difficiles de la
planète et surtout pouvoir faire
partager cette passion un métier qui
pour lui est le plus beau au monde même
s'il représente d'énormes risqu pour sa
propre
[Musique]
vie si un jour j'avais des enfants je me
retrouverai dans la même situation que
mon père si mon fils me disait je veux
être alpiniste
je pense que je me comporterai de la
même façon je ne pourrais pas lui
refuser mais il n'y aurait aucun
encouragement de ma
part ce serait à lui de décider et
j'espère qu'il prendrait la bonne
décision Gérard et Sébastien sont de
passionnés de la montagne ils font tous
les deux un travail où la vie ne dépend
que d'une
ce ils savent qu'il n' pas le droit à
l'erreur mais rien au monde il ne
changeraiit quoi que ce soit ils tracent
leur chemin mettent en place toute la
sécurité qu'ils peuvent et surtout font
confiance au
[Musique]
destin